I always thought shadow banning was a real thing.
But I think he came out and said that that's not a real thing.
But I've seen it in my,
you know,
in person where I'll type somebody's name in and usually it splits to come up on
the searches,
but it doesn't,
you know,
shadow banning is if it is a real thing,
like that's another one like shadow banning for what?
Like if it,
if it's not something that is,
if you're not doing something that you could get kicked off the platform for it,
right.
You're not taking them off,
you just pushing them down weird place.
But if you're doing that,
like why are you doing that?
Like what?
Because like,
uh,
but what would be the justification from the ones that I have seen three used to
even be a website that you could type in somebody's user name to see if their
shadow bands.
So that's kind of interesting.
But,
uh,
like a lot of porn stars or shadow banned cause they don't want,
if you're looking up Christina Applegate,
they want Christina,
you know,
apple bottom or something like that.
You know what I mean?
So it's,
it's like I still believe that's a thing,
but I'm pretty sure he came out and said it wasn't a real thing.
Technically a shadow banning Justin Bieber from the trending topics.
Right.
I mean,
they had publicly said that that's not a shadow ban.
That's a strategy.
Well,
no,
there were kind of forced into it because Justin Bieber was so,
his fans trend so hard.
They hashtag the shit out of that thing and they just took over the trending.
It's probably happening for other equally popular celebrities too.
Like Taylor swift's and beyond con.
Yeah.
You're probably right.
So whatever they're doing at youtube with comments and whatever they're doing
with Twitter,
here's the real conversation,
right?
The real conversation is,
do we want that?
Do we want them to cure rate?
Do we want them to decide whose youtube videos you could subscribe to and who?
I mean,
do they unsubscribe people?
Is that real or is that a glitch?
Who knows?
I don't think they,
I'm subscribed.
I don't think so either.
But people have,
let's listen.
If they're willing to move Justin Bieber from the number one trending because
he'd number one trends too hard and they think it's ridiculous not to just
acknowledge that our culture,
there's certain humans in our culture of spending an exorbitant amount of time
thinking about that beautiful man,
right?
There's a lot.
But why do we want to lie and pretend that it's not as big.
So if they just,
I'm not saying they shouldn't,
but if they did that just,
if they did that,
you go,
okay,
well we,
through the looking glass,
now you can change the data.
Like what?
What do you lend?
When do you decide who gets pushed here?
Who gets pushed there?
When do you decide.